l'intervention de la police s'est
déroulée dans le calme il est 8h30
lorsque les bus peuvent enfin quitter le
site
une trentaine de manifestants issus de
plusieurs syndicats ont bloqué le dépôt
pour protester contre la réforme des
retraites
nous considérons que nous sommes dans un
rapport de force nous sommes dans une
démarche totalement politique ça c'est
clair nous le revendiquons et nous
estimons que pour faire avancer nos
revendications c'est à dire le retrait
du projet de loi mais négocier également
une amélioration du régime actuel nous
devons en passer par là une action menée
très tôt ce matin à l'heure où les
chauffeurs de tram et de bus prennent
leur service
alors on a eu un impact sur le trafic au
fur et à mesure dans la dans la matinée
20 dans le manteau dans la matinée
puisqu'on avait sorti une dizaine de
tram sur lignes t1 et t2 donc et une
fréquence de 15 minutes est en moyenne
trois à quatre bus par ligne mais
derrière dans la montée au fur et à
mesure de capacité du réseau à partir de
6 à 6h30 on n'a pas pu faire plus le
trafic pour les usagers a repris
normalement aux alentours de 9h30
le collectif interlude prévoit déjà
d'autres actions dans les jours à venir